let's go next to our caller from the 6-8
to area code who's calling today from
682 hi David my name is sapore I'm
calling from Austin Texas hey how are
you today I'm good how are you good
what's on your mind so I see now that
Joe Biden has thrown his hat into the
ring and he's such a popular establish
it can't establishment candidate I have
a hypothetical question okay Joe Biden
were to win the primary and then go on
to win the presidency what if any more
recently popular leftist policies like
medic for all preschool etc might be
actually get to see or remove those just
dead in the water
now in this hypothetical future very
good question so if which ones is Joe
Biden going to personally make a
priority to champion if he is president
none but and I'm gonna try to think
about this as hypothetically optimistic
I mean I don't support Biden I'd vote
for the guy if he's the nominee because
I think he's better than Trump but I
want to make it clear I'm not a Biden
guy although I think he's a good debater
and people say David how can you say
that and it's like now he's a good
debater I just don't think he's that
progressive yeah the opportunity if
Biden is present is that there is at
least the chance that if Democrats can
take over the Senate not likely in 2020
but maybe in 2022 and control the house
I don't believe Biden will get in the
way of those reforms if Democrats in the
House and Senate managed to push them
through maybe I'm naive but if the
question as asked is is Biden going to
make that stuff happen the answer is no
right right yeah that's just what I
thought my boyfriend seems to think that
we should wait to hear what he has to
say but I think that we have decades of
you know all the records that we need to
know oh yeah sure I mean listen if Joe
Biden next week puts out new policy says
here's my new revised presidential
policy I'm for Medicare for all I'm for
free college I'm for you know if they do
Fieri rule for financial whatever right
those would all be changes and I would
welcome them and that would be really
great but for the time being I don't
write it's crazy to go based on the
record of him as a politician for
decades
I absolutely agree I have one more thing
sort of related to well totally related
to you how you were looking at them
researching Bernie supporters who
changed their votes to Trump in 2016
right this is kind of an anecdote so in
2016 you know mom and I would go to the
feed store where we you you chat people
up and one of the kids working there was
talking about how he was super into
Bernie and we would just kind of like go
on and on about him then when he lost
when Bernie lost the primary the cave
was talking about Donald Trump if he was
going to vote for Donald Trump and we
were like what how did this happen and
he said why just wanted free college so
it looks like he went from wanting this
very leftist candidate for free college
which is you know considered a leftist
thing in America yeah to Donald Trump
and I guess you know I just was it
Enrique talking earlier a little bit
about how they just wanted to tear
everything down and build it back up
right um it's just an anecdote that I
think it all some hired yeah well it's
an anecdote of about 12% of Bernie
supporters which is disturbingly high
right yeah right all right support thank
you so much really appreciate the call
great to hear from Austin Texas